Fabien: Salut, aujourd'hui je suis à Aix en Provence.
On est en pleine tournée avec Garyzor
Voici l'activité principale d'un régisseur en tournée...
Gary : Je conduis des voitures
Fabien: Faut rien lui dire, parce que,
en fait, il n'a pas le permis et... euh...
ne brisons pas ses rêves.
[Musique Générique]
Alors, on a commencé la tournée
le 6 janvier à Lille,
Aujourd'hui je suis à Aix en Provence.
Pour ceux qui suivent la chaîne depuis longtemps,
il y a un an, jour pour jour,
j'étais déjà en spectacle ici.
Ça résonne toujours autant !
Sauf que la différence par rapport
à l'année dernière
c'est que vous êtes nombreux à
m'avoir découvert sur la chaîne
et à venir découvrir le spectacle.
Et je suis assez surpris des discussions
qu'on a après le spectacle...
Ce qui revient le plus c'est que vous
ne vous attendiez pas à voir ça sur scène,
et je me demande, du coup,
à quoi vous vous attendiez ?
Il y a un couple, hier soir,
c'est à dire mercredi soir;
c'est le mec qui est venue avec ça meuf ;
elle lui avait dit : "Bon, tu vas voir,
ce n'est pas très drôle, mais c'est intéressant."
Et je me suis dit :"Ah, d'accord,
c'est ça l'image que je renvoie dans les vidéos !"
Et c'est normal : c'est vrai que
je ne mets pas forcément d'humour dans les vidéos.
Moi, pour faire de l'humour,
j'ai besoin d'être avec des personnes.
J'ai besoin d'être en interaction.
Mais au moins ça m'a donné l'idée
de me dire :
"Attends ! Avant la vidéo de samedi,
parce que je pense que je vais sortir
une vidéo samedi,
je vais faire celle-ci rapidement
pour dire, en fait, quelle est la
différence entre les vidéos et la scène."
Alors, d'abord peut-être un point commun :
un des points communs c'est que,
en vidéo, j'essaye de vous transmettre des choses
et sur scène c'est pareil, il y a
des choses que je transmets.
Une différence maintenant :
c'est que, en vidéo, quand je mets la vidéo,
j'ai besoin d'attendre quelques heures,
voire quelques jours
avant de savoir ce que vous en pensez.
Sur scène c'est immédiat.
Si je dis une blague et qu'elle n'est pas drôle,
je le sais tout de suite.
Par contre, si elle est drôle,
je le sais aussi.
Dans les vidéos, le nombre d'abonnés,
même si j'ai conscience
que vous êtes des gens
de l'autre côté,
juste là !
Ça reste aussi un nombre,
un chiffre...
Alors que dans un spectacle,
je vous vois pour de vrai.
Et on peut échanger.
Et je rencontre des gens incroyables
et formidables.
Hier soir j'ai quand même rencontré
Flavien !
Flavien qui m'a fait ces magnifiques
cadeaux.
Regardez, juste ici.
Je vous en fais voir deux d'entre elles.
C'est de la bière que le mec fait lui-même.
La bière d'Aix en Provence.
L'Aquae Maltae
On en a goutté deux avec Gary
sur les quatre...
c'est un petit bijou.
Dans le spectacle, c'est vrai que
je fais beaucoup participer le public.
Mais attention, ce n'est que
les personnes qui le veulent.
Je ne force pas qui que ce soit
à faire quoi que ce soit.
Les personnes qui veulent vraiment
participer ce soir, vous pouvez lever la main.
Ça n'arrive jamais, sauf sur le gens bizares,
je vous repère à ce moment là.
Voilà, c'est pratique, hein ?
[Rires du public]
Non, non !
N'hésitez pas, allez-y !
Alors des fois, oui c'est vrai,
par contre dans le spectacle
en essayant de vous transmettre des choses,
j'utilise des termes un peu techniques...
Je sais déjà que c'est un homme
qui l'a écrit.
Parce qu'en graphologie
on a des termes techniques...
Là par exemple, je peux le dire,
le terme technique c'est
que c'est écrit comme un cochon.
[Rires du public]
Et nous les mecs, ne mentons pas,
on écrit très mal !
Ok ?
Et puis, évidemment, mon but
c'est de vous bluffer
avec des choses, comme ça,
si possible assez incroyables, quoi...
Néanmoins, l'homme qui a écrit ça,
il a écrit ça...euh... un petit peu
au dessus de la ligne,
en dehors du cadre.
Et ça, c'est un signe d'intelligence,
et de vivacité d'esprit.
J'aime bien parce que là j'ai
Jean-Marie et Cédric qui font
"Écoute, je ne veux pas de vexer,
mais..."
[Rires du public]
Le monsieur est mentaliste,
il a deviné...
Et d'une manière générale,
durant les 1h30, 1h40 que durent le spectacle,
je vous fais découvrir le mentalisme
sous toutes ses formes.
Parfois c'est vous qui vous auto-bluffez
en découvrant quelque chose en même temps que moi.
Et puis je vous fais partager un petit peu plus
ma vie et mon humour
qui, je crois,
est universel.
Puisque je me suis aperçu d'un truc
très drôle dans les annuaires :
Ça marche avec tous les départements
et toutes les années.
Si vous regardez bien un annuaire,
à chaque page,
on ne fait pas attention la première fois...
Mais regardez bien !
A chaque fois !
[Excessivement amusé]
Chaque page !
Il y a systématiquement
trois colonnes par page !
Chaque fois !
Chaque page !
[Redevenant brusquement sérieux]
[Rires du public]
C'est de l'humour de mentaliste,
tu ne peux pas comprendre.
[Rires du public]
Chacun ses blagues, c'est tout.
Chacun ses blagues...
Bref, être sur scène, avec vous,
c'est aussi
une manière de créer des liens
entre nous, encore plus forts
que les commentaires ou les vidéos.
Des fois un petit peu trop fort...
on ne va pas se mentir...
Appuie bien, il ne faut pas
que je puisse voir, hein...
[Rires du public]
Alors, il ne faut pas que je puisse voir,
Maxime, mais il faut que je puisse entendre...
L'idée ce n'est pas de boucher tous les trous,
juste les yeux...
[Rires du public]
[Fabien expire]
Et puis, évidemment, à la fin du spectacle
on se renconte,
en général pendant 1h30
La première date, le 6 janvier,
j'avais passé 3h40 de dédicaces
ceux qui étaient là s'en souviennes...
Donc 1h30 sur scène,
3h40 en dédicaces
on a vite fait le calcul,
avant la fin de la tournée j'allais décéder.
Si vous vous avez déjà vu le spectacle,
n'hésitez pas à le dire dans les commentaires,
dites moi ce que vous en avez pensé
réellement,
n'hésitez pas.
Ça fait plaisir d'avoir un retour.
Et puis pour ceux qui veulent venir,
il y a toutes les dates sur le site Internet
Je vous l'ai dit,
le mois prochain je fais...
4 représentations à Toulon
2 à Versailles,
c'est la date la plus proche de Paris...
6 dates à Grenoble
et puis après sur les autres mois
il y aura encore d'autres villes
Bordeaux, etc...
Il y a tout sur le site Internet.
J'espère avoir un peu plus répondu
à cette question
qui allait partout aussi dans les commentaires
de "Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce spectacle ?"
Donc, grosso-modo, le mentalisme
c'est le fond,
l'humour c'est la forme.
C'est un one-man-show
de mentalisme.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu,
comme d'habitude vous pouvez
mettre un bon like
et vous abonner.
Et rendez-vous sûrement samedi matin
Ciao.
[Musique Générique de fin]